pizza hut is pushing another radical
ideology pizza hut
through the pizza hut foundation is
pushing critical race theory
they are presenting training pamphlets
for teachers that make statements such
as quote racism exists within and beyond
schools and communities of learning
the myth of a racial hierarchy remains a
dominant part of america's culture acts
of violence against black communities
are often identified on social media by
the hashtag black lives matter you know
all of these you know this epidemic
black men can't even walk out their
doors without being hunted down says
lebron james
pizza hut this pizza hut is pushing this
crap
pizza the silence of little caesars is
deafening like when will little caesars
speak up against racism or whatever
pizza why is pizza hut doing this well
because pizza hut has this non-profit
foundation a non-governmental non-profit
foundation which is pushing this
radicalism
we don't have a vote in what pizza hut
does
right pizza hut is not
a democratic institution
and it's not exactly affiliated with the
government but this is how the liberal
establishment rules they rule through a
series of ngos and non-profit groups
that push their crap that are basically
insulated from the political process
for now and they should not be we should
we should
use the political process
to bring them into line
i don't care
if
it is the government
destroying my way of life and completely
upending america's society or if it's
some corporation
okay i don't if if someone is treading
on me to give the image of the gadsden
flag it doesn't make me feel any better
if the organization that is treading on
me is google okay it doesn't make me
feel any better if it's facebook taking
away my rights and my liberties and my
way of life
rather than the government say
we've got to get better about this as
conservatives we've for a couple of
decades fell into this very stupid idea
of well you know google's a private
company they have the right to do
whatever they want twitter build your
own twitter right as though that has
ever worked
if you go back
to the early days of the modern
conservative movement frankly if you go
back to some of the most libertarian
figures
in the conservative movement
they were advocating
not just focusing on the government and
letting quote-unquote private industry
do whatever they want
they were advocating bringing private
enterprise into
line as well
barry goldwater
as for mr conservative at the early days
of the conservative movement and also
extremely libertarian in that early
alliance between the libertarians and
the traditional conservatives barry
goldwater wrote in conscience of a
conservative quote
let us henceforth make war on all
monopolies whether corporate or union
the enemy of freedom is unrestrained
power and the champions of freedom will
fight against the concentration of power
wherever they find it yeah man that's
good stuff that's clear thinking
of course
we're not going to just let
random ngos and very powerful
corporations completely upend our
society
and just throw our hands in the air and
say well their private industry well
their private organizations know we're
gonna fight back and we're gonna use the
political order to do it in a way that
is just and fair but we've got to fight
back i'm glad you like that clip now
hold up
ring the bell
subscribe
leave a comment maybe if you liked the
clip
make sure you get the notifications for
future videos also head on over to apple
podcast spotify stitcher wherever you
get your audio podcast subscribe to the
michael knowles show leave a five star
review we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]